after going dark for well over a year oh  by cirque du soleil is preparing to take  the stage again on the first of july  there's the crew holding their first  practice inside the bellagio  it's been so long the artists say really  an emotional experience being back and  getting used to things again  getting launched from the russian swing  is very much like coming off of a roller  coaster when you come over the top  you just get that weightlessness in your  stomach and your body before you shoot  down  for the last 14 months there hasn't been  anything that we can do to even remotely  get the same feeling that we get when  we're in the air here oh that looks fun  tickets on sale now and can be bought at  cirque du soleil.com looking at this  video denise  they are still after that long break in  really good form  they sure are that's really that's  quintessential vegas right there  yes it is